so "Black New York" is a course that I
teach here at Columbia University which
really encourages students to think
about not just Columbia's relationship
to Harlem but think about the black
experience throughout the city. As a
Bronxite I think it's very important for
our students to get a sense of the black
experience in New York beyond Harlem,
right? So looking at historic
neighborhoods in Brooklyn or in the Bronx
or in Queens and even going further
downtown looking at places like the
African burial ground which is a
historically significant site in
Manhattan in lower Manhattan so the
course really is allowing students to get in
immersion into the particularities and
the dynamic cultures of the black
experience New York City. In recent years my
work has turned to sports and its
relationship to American identity
national identity and politics. I think
sport is a really fascinating venue to
look at all sorts of questions: what we
think about manhood and womanhood, gender
identity, what we think about our nation,
patriotism, sports' relationship to
the larger political economy. So sports
and looking at relationship to these
changing identities in politics allows
us to understand I think U.S. society in
new and novel ways